greed and fear are pretty high up on the
list it's interesting though how complex
human motivation is in in shaping the
process that we call history there were
people who were unquestionably actuated
by greed by the profit motive when they
crossed the Atlantic and began the
process of colonization of the new world
that ultimately produced lo and behold
the United States but there were also
people who were convinced they were
going to build a new Jerusalem whose
motivations were primarily religious and
it's it's striking to me how powerful
those missionary impulses remain even
into the 21st century people do behave
in ways that are not simply profit
maximizing a lot of what gets done by
nongovernmental organizations today is
analogous to what missionary societies
were doing in the nineteenth century
it's just that the motivations are
secular in many cases then at all rather
than than religious so there's an
interplay to put it really simply
between economic motivations but also on
the other side religious or ideological
motivations if you prefer then itself as
a simplification because within that
broad interplay of forces individual
motives can in fact be highly
complicated and even irrational because
human beings are not well designed by
evolution to make careful calculations
of probability we know from a lot of
work that's been done by behavioral
psychologists how bad people are at
assessing their own self-interest and
how poorly they attach probabilities to
future scenarios and how readily they
make snap decisions rather than weighing
evidence so a really critical force as
important as the profit motive as greed
as important as as religion ideology and
the
year is human stupidity and in many ways
of the three I suspect that that central
inability of the individual human being
efficient they to calculate
self-interest and accurately to attach
probabilities to future scenarios that
is really the main driving force in
history and it is remarkable given the
force of stupidity that there has been
any material progress at all but then I
can saw myself the the thought that
although we have made enormous leaps and
bounds in the realm of economics and the
realm of science we live longer we live
more comfortably we have better physical
health during our lives all of this is
one of the most astonishing achievements
of humanity we have made life materially
so much better and most of that
improvement happened in the last hundred
years but before you get carried away
and conclude that history is a
progressive phenomenon remember in the
process we've done enormous harm to our
environment to other human beings who
haven't shared in the benefits and we
have developed the technology to destroy
ourselves and all living things so
that's what I mean by human stupidity I
maybe I'm putting it too crudely but let
me be more precise about the human
inability accurately to assess future
scenarios and probabilities and
individual self-interest